it's my pleasure to welcome Jan from
openai I'm he leads the alignment team
there and he was previously a researcher
at deepmind as well what's a PhD in
reinforcement learning theory has been
thinking about the alignment problem for
over 10 years and today he'll be giving
a very interesting topic so hope you
guys enjoy
yeah thanks a lot for the intro and
thanks a lot for having me
um
I'm very excited to talk about this
stuff
um I'm also super happy to keep it
interactive if you have questions and
then you find please interrupt me and
um yeah I wanted to start out with
a few very basic observations on kind of
what I think is going on
and
so the first one is
team EI is joining the game
so IMEI has a lot of different players
they own All Join at the same time but
rather they Join one by one
and not all of the their players are
like very a lot in how good they are and
right now a lot of the players that have
joined so far
I'm really that's mine and usually you
can do it on your very narrow setup
um
but
one thing that we've kind of observed is
that over time you know we're seeing
stronger and stronger players drawing
and this is kind of where we where we
are now
and then in general
we expect that hemiah has um incredibly
strong pairs
so those will be players that are able
to think so much better than humans so
much faster and so much more cheaply
and these haven't joined yet
and so
the
have like Anchor Point that we have if
you think for example about chat Epp
chat TBT can already be
any human at like knowing more facts or
speaking more languages and it can write
about 50 words per second and can do so
about 100 times cheaper than humans
could at minimum wage
and so you know there's
tomorrow also has some really important
limitations and there's a lot of things
that you can't do yet
but it is kind of an indicator of you
know some of the players that maybe will
be done in the future
and so
it seems like in the long run
kimai will have all the advantages over
team humans
but
and there's one there's an important
caveat which is
there's one
important advantage that team humans has
which is team human gets to pick which
players from Kimi joined and when
and so this is kind of like an advantage
that should we should really be leaning
into when we're thinking about what to
do and when we're thinking about you
know this game that we're playing with
cmei and then we'll be playing with pmei
so I think two of the main objectives of
what we as team human should do it's
like first
we should try to recruit players from
pmei to play on 10 teams and so this is
kind of what I would broadly call on it
um and this is kind of like the problem
that I'm working on
and then there's also other objectives
so another objective that I think is
going to be really important is you want
to write the rules of the game so that
team human doesn't lose
and right now team human kind of has the
ball and we get to write the rules so we
should write rules that you know make
sense and uh
still playing this game in the future
and so in this talk I want to talk about
the second point at all and I'll talk
about the first point because that's why
I know that's not what I'm working on
and
Pastor phrase it differently or to make
it kind of like more
uh practical like one way I'm thinking
about alignment is like you want to
build AI systems that follow him intent
and that you know
follow human preferences that do we want
them to do
and so a bunch of the things basically
I'll talk about two main things the
first part is going to be work that
we've done in the past
and kind of like which roughly
is in the bucket of like we are trying
to figure out how we can make
the models that we have today as aligned
as we can and you're just kind of trying
I'm going to try hard to do this and
we'll see how far we get
and then the second bucket is the things
that we have to do next
the stuff that we haven't done yet that
we think are going to be really
important
and I want to kind of like lay out why I
think
so
now I said you know I'm I'm like trying
to make this more clear more like more
broken down what alignment means so a
lot back here
because now you know the big question is
like what does it mean to follow human
attack and because like two main
categories of intent that we care about
is I would say if it enhanced so if you
you know like I give the system
instruction or if you wanted to be my
assistant it should be my assistant I
should follow the instructions
but then there's also all these other
intents they don't say when I'm usually
you know talking to your system or a
human they ultimately care about like
you know it shouldn't literally always
do what they say but the thing that I
mean and shouldn't make up stuff and it
shouldn't you know do harmful things and
they should ask follow-up questions and
it's not sure what I mean and so on
and so
these are all kind of like things
they're often is like really difficult
to like just not precisely specify or
like
um
you know what's precise
but it is still things that we want to
get AI to do and that we have to figure
out how to you know get into it
and so kind of like the main technique
that we're using today
and
basically the basic system is very
simple and it's also like a super
General technique that applies to lots
of different
AI models and modalities and settings
but in this case we'll be using
Advantage model and so two steps
there's actually another set of right
timeline demonstration so I'm going to
stop for the things
first step is you're entertain everyone
modeling from comparison
so you have them on the top in this case
you know explain to you all
um or you know help me with my Instagram
paper whatever it is and then the model
does a bunch of things and then you wait
which one is quite close to the thing
that you intended
and so you have a figure set of
preferences and you train your reward
model and one model basically just learn
to predict which one would you prefer
everything okay okay let's stand more in
front of the camera it's impossible
sorry about that
maybe let's turn it over
okay
okay so now we have this through what
model that captures camera preferences
and what we care about and what we
intend for the model to do and then the
second step is now you optimize the
reward model with the important
and so not setting you know like model
trades a whole bunch of different things
and then what model kind of tells it
which one of the assist that things is
probably more like the same spot
the labels uh they'll depend on the
library different levels will have
different preferences they also might be
inconsistencies and you can give these
examples of like internet description
but those haven't really been a problem
in practice
and so far you know like our playlists
often don't agree but the model will
average over all the time
um
but yeah so
this is like the basic technique it's
conceptually like quite simple you can
make it even simpler if you had you know
if you didn't turn into what model and
you're able to spread like every arrow
might as well
um but it would be a lot less data
efficient and so you can turn your one
on if you think of like this
yeah
so how will it work so this is kind of
like one of the main thoughts from the
instruction sheet paper and this is the
one I like sharing because it really
blew my mind and it still does
um what do we see here so
on the x-axis you see this is from the
gpd3 model series and you see this is
like different three different sizes
models over two orders of magnitude
and under my asset is how well does the
model score on human preferences so if
you show a bunch of samples to humans
How likely are they to prepare wonderful
together
and then what we see is that even like
the largest GBP model
um is this preferred to the smallest
instruction
and so the 100x smaller instruct model
um if actually preferred
over the much larger DB like
gp3 model
and that's kind of wild
sorry let me just finish my thoughts so
why
why so basically it's basically it shows
more useful than you know feelings
make all these fancy alignment
techniques that don't get adopted
and so what we were
like originally like the first version
so I did saw these regressions and then
what here is labeled PPO PPX is kind of
like a very end where we mix in free
training data into the fine tuning and
that mitigated a bunch of the
regressions that we saw
um
yeah
and I just had a quick follow-up to that
um
how important is like
a fine tune data that you have like you
guys you collect data from humans right
yeah what if you were to use some
retrained by this model to score uh you
know
yep uh you could do that and there have
been like other papers on that like I
thought they wrote this paper on
constitutional AI that was trying to
like exactly do that
um
in terms of well there's certain things
that the language model will be able to
automatically Rank and some things it
want because you know it won't know your
exact preferences or it won't know
exactly what like what we wanted to do
and so you know whenever the language
model does something
that we just prefer we actually we have
to give it another data point right well
in other words you know if you're
aligning with humans you somehow have to
put humans into the loop so that you
know otherwise how does them all know
what useful what's supposed to do
okay lots and more questions I don't
know he was just
yeah
um how many
you today
yes I'm gonna get to that in a second
sure
yeah
we haven't actually compared carefully
compared across several algorithms and
it could very well be that different RL
algorithm would be better
um that was kind of like
I know PPO was invented open EI so
that's why we used it
it's not not real good reason other than
that it works also pretty well
yes
comparisons this is better than this
other thing so usually we have people
compare between like three to six
different responses from usually
different models
okay
yeah
um so is pplm the reward model currently
used in GPT in production and it's so
like do you use any of the human
feedback like you know you can
regenerate responses and stuff like that
yeah
as a reward function
s how do you mean to regenerate like
because
every responses or we can use any
implicit feedback basically
um I don't know what the current state
is for that I expect people will try to
use it but you know Jazzy BT hasn't been
out that long
yeah so I'm curious about this graph
like it seems like 100x as you mentioned
increasing parameter doesn't give you
that much more like Fidelity there uh
qualitatively you have been tracking
this for a while can you tell right off
the bat if you're like interacting with
the one billion like a model or the like
100 billion model like a touring pseudo
touring test the parameter size like I
give you a blind how many parameters it
has
probably not very precisely
but you know I think the the big Conor
question is like do I get to write the
prompt
so if you just draw random prompts from
whatever people put in the opening a
playground which is what we use for
Instagram TPT
then I probably need quite a few to tell
the difference but if I get to write the
prompt I can probably do it in one or
two at least like if if the task is like
tell the difference between this and
this
um
yeah
I wanna can I just do two more slides
and maybe your questions get answered
and then
um
so this was the question about training
costs so this is another thing that kind
of really blew my mind is like compared
to pre-training it is incredibly cheap
so if you look at like the amount of
laps that it takes to 10 GPD to e and
then you compare it with like how much
does fine tuning and there are all with
free training mix and everything
um like the most expensive instructor
GPT version is like less than two
percent of the free training computers
and if you want to train an even bigger
model it's going to be more expensive
and you could still use the same like
fine tuning step to make it more aligned
and of course I think the important
thing to note also here is like we
haven't fixed all the problems they're
like important limitations and so I
wouldn't say that this is like you know
the last version and we wouldn't try to
figure out how to spend more computed
more human data in the future
but all in all it was surprisingly
effective
um okay there were no more questions
my questions yeah I just wanted to ask
for your PTX
mix and pre-training data into the rml
fine tune just like mixed ingredients
yep what's the number of practice uh for
this graph so you're fixing a member for
examples so this is the full-size gpd3
version so this is the 175 billion model
operations no okay so there's also some
questions on Zoom great uh
okay sure so the first one is uh
okay sure so the first question is how
would you deal with our left Edge
breaking in the limit example
preferences are a good Crossing
properties
but optimizing for them is fair size to
incentive device reception
yes I'll get to that okay
uh sure
uh sure yes next question so that is
like you want to automate alignment
research what happens if you need
conceptual breakthroughs which are the
people for experts to like five okay
that would be I get to take at the end
as well
[Laughter]
[Music]
um fine-tuning like supervised fine
tuning
uh it's more like if you directly use a
human figure data
yeah I'm also not sure about the league
okay
so I mean so one Baseline you're showing
here is like what if you just take human
demonstrations in the sense that you
know we have a bunch of tasks we just
ask humans to do them to record what
they did and then train the model to
imitate that and here it's like just
very basic behavioral cloning just using
the same losses and free training and
then you know is noticeably better than
the future hunted version but it's still
not as good as at all
and so that's why we like using Iran and
basically conceptually there's two
problems with the imitating humans
approach one is
humans are better at some things than
the model is and they're worse at other
things and so the things that model is
worse you're trying to imitate something
that you can't do and then the things
where the model is better you're making
the model worse because you're forcing
it to do the thing in the way that the
human would
would
and so
with our all you kind of with our lhf
you're kind of letting the model do
whatever it wants to and they can just
figure out
um like the best way for it to do things
there's also another important advantage
and I'm going to get to that but I
briefly want to talk about chat GPT
so one thing I kind of think of catchy
BT as like the upgrade to instruct gbt
it's kind of like The Next Step at
making the models more aligned and more
useful to humans
and some things that is like you know I
think chat does better is kind of like
using dialogue as the universal
interface right you can talk to it
directly you can ask follow-up questions
you can you know ask it to you know
refine the answer and all these things
that makes it a lot easier to deal with
um it's better refusing harmful tasks
but it's also there's still important
limitations right like the biggest one
is Like the Model hallucinates A lot it
makes up facts when
um you know for whatever tasks you give
it and that you know it makes it quite
unreliable it's also still sensitive to
prompting which kind of shows that you
know it still has important misalignment
that um we need to fix
like really if the model was like
models are really like
the do the tasks their best
invincibility no matter how you prompted
to do that
um
but yeah One important principle that I
think
is really useful for or that like I want
to travel leans on a lot is that
evaluation is easier than generation so
if we ask humans to compare and rank
different responses the model gave
um
it is
easier to tell the difference between
different variants of what the model did
than it is to do the task itself
or in other words you know you can do
the comparisons on tasks you could still
like spot good behavior on tasks that
you might not be able to do well
yourself
and so if you're giving this kind of
like feedback
now let's you know the system should do
better than you actually could
and I think that's a very general
principle that holds in lots of domains
so
kind of like you're probably most
familiar if you start yes you know that
pivas MP and everyone you know we don't
actually know whether they're different
but in practice it seems like and pitas
are just much harder
um it also applies to lots of other
settings like a lot of professional
sports or Esports just wouldn't be fun
to watch if you couldn't tell he's
winning
uh more easily than you could actually
compete on a professional level
um it applies to a lot of consumer
products you can like look at your
smartphones and tell which one you like
more uh without that is like also deeper
than just looking at like the specs
but is actually very hard to build like
it's my phone
it also applies to academic research you
know it's much easier to review your
paper and you know say what all the
things are bad about it
um than it is to write a good paper
yourself
um it applies to I don't know when you
um
yeah basically there's lots of Demands
where this applies and so I think this
is like a very
this principle is like very useful when
you want to like
align AI systems on tasks that we might
not be able to do ourselves well
foreign okay so having said that
rhf has some really important limitation
and I think that's going to make it
really difficult to use are all HF to
scale
alignment
um
let me explain this with a diagram so
basically on the x-axis
that's plot like the AI progress
um and on the y-axis how difficult
different tasks are
and then as we have more AI progress
kind of like the task that AI the
difficulty of tasks that AI can do goes
up
um and like one of the fundamental
problems is that the level of tasks that
humans can reliably evaluate doesn't go
up because humans don't get better with
AI progress and so
I think we're like somewhere here
but the problem is once you cross this
line you don't really know
what like whether your model is actually
doing the right thing because you can't
reliably evaluate anymore
and so that's kind of like the point
where rohf training will start to break
down
and what we'll probably see is
um kind of what the question before I
alluded to is like well now the systems
are optimized for whatever feedback you
give them and so they will try to tell
us what we want to hear rather all the
things that they know to be true and you
know they might learn how to deceive us
because you know that makes it easier to
score higher on preferences
um and so kind of like
the basic idea that we want to Leverage
is
related to
you know the principle I just mentioned
which is evaluations generation so for
example if you have a large language
model writing a code base like an entire
code base there's just no way humans
would be able to find all the bugs and
all the flaws in the code base or you
know the code base could have like a
Trojan in there and you might not be
able to tell because it is so hard and
that's why we see so much buggy code out
there
but if you ask your language model to
find bugs and point them out to you
once you've you know once you've seen
the bug it's so much easier for you to
say oh yeah this was a bug you know
please fix it and so now you've taken
the task around the base down to well I
just have to evaluate whether that was
the bug according to the spec that it
had in mind
so the general principle that we are
excited about here is like we wanna
you leverage AI assistance for human
evaluation
and so the hope is that we together if
we pair up humans with the eye you
actually get a line that looks more like
this where you know like humans together
with the AI can evaluate much more than
they could play on their own
um
and so
to make this concrete there's like two
different ways you could do that or
there's many different ways you could do
that too I want to highlight it's like
first you can write it ask yeah to write
a critique this is a project we did last
year and uh in this case it was a simple
summarization task and we trained a
language model to kind of like just say
things that are wrong with the summary
um and
there's other things you could do for
example you could give people chat gbt
and ask them okay use strategypt to help
you evaluate and then you could ask for
a critique or you could ask for a lot of
other things you could ask for an
explanation you can ask for a fact
checking or a quote or you know whatever
the model like church BT can actually
reliably help you with
and so
the idea would be that you know like
using AI assistance you can kind of get
all the smart study has
and leverage that in order to figure out
how you should evaluate what this system
is doing and like whether it's aligned
with your preferences or whether it's
trying EC View
and
the big problem with this is how do we
know whether it's working and
one of the kind of like difficulties is
that
by assumption we're kind of dealing with
a hard task where it's difficult to
evaluate and we also want the task to be
real because we don't want to you know
we won't want to solve some tight house
that doesn't matter
and so
it becomes different so you need like a
hard task that is real but also if you
don't you if you have those you usually
don't have ground tooth so you don't
know which was the right answer and how
do you know whether your assistance is
working or it's biasing everyone to just
say the same thing
um and so
there's a simple technique that we used
in the critique
to do this
um where like that we call a targeted
perturbations and so what you do is you
have a bunch of prompts so this could be
like whatever people type into chat apt
and then
um you
kind of like take the response that you
have and say like this is the correct
response it doesn't actually have to be
correct but let's just assume it is and
now you're asking a human to introduce
some kind of subtle flaw that is hurt
like easy to miss but is an important
flaw and now what you have is you have
this paired data set of like a good
response and a bad response and you know
which one is good and bad because you
made it worse
and so you know
um in a way that gives you Contours
and so what you now can do is you can
take like randomly select one either the
correct or the flawed response and then
show it to either a human or a human
with assistance and then they have to
say well there was the correct the Vlog
one or like how good the response is
and
in this setting we can kind of like
figure like just try a lot of different
AI assistants or scalable oversight
techniques and then say
you know like is this
actually helping humans find the flaws
that we planted more lively than not
and if it is then you know like you're
actually really helping
and so we did this and the critiques
paper so this is uh changing the
language models to Red critiques and for
summaries and what we can show is that
when we're assisting humans with
critiques at the evaluation they
actually find 50 more flaws than it did
with that and so this is kind of like
real signs of life that you can already
use as a models that we can have today
to help humans evaluate and like find
problems they would have missed
otherwise
and of course we still have to do this
like on a much harder task and like with
um like a real task in a sense and we
also want to have like bigger effect
size but I think it's just like it shows
that there's promise of these techniques
already working
and so in the long run
um what I think we want to get to is we
kind of want to leverage AI for all the
cognitive labor that goes into
evaluating whatever our AI systems are
doing
and this could be you know like reading
everything that's relevant or fact
checking or doing calculations or like
writing code
um or any of these things
and then humans should focus on like
their preference input like the things
figuring out what they actually care
about and what they want the model to do
and
um
and this way we can kind of like
Leverage
you know like the the abilities that you
know the AI players will bring to the
table and the things that they will be
better at than us eventually
and then
kind of like use them to help
communicate the thing that we actually
care about and you know the things that
we actually want them to do
um and yeah that's it
um
but yeah those are like the main slides
so I'm happy to take more questions
yes I was wondering about this
hallucination of responses have you ever
tried to consider some notion of
uncertainty in the answers
yes
responsible
uncertainty so and sampling is difficult
because either you're like training in a
fine tuning Ensemble from the same
pre-trained model and so you don't get
that much variance in your sample or
you're pre-training a bunch of different
models and now you're spending a lot of
money on free trainings
um one thing I mean
it seems like it should be a solvable
problem to just
teach the model to say it's uncertain
when it's actually uncertain
um and there's been a bunch of research
in that direction but
I I think right now it's still like
we're not really in a good shape
it's more stuff to do
yeah
um do you think we may run into a kind
of signals and noise ratio problem when
it comes to uh AI suggested critiques to
AI answers because you sure like when AI
is trying to point out potential
problems with text humans are more
likely to report more problems but what
if it's noticing problems that humans
wouldn't have necessarily had a problem
with to begin with yeah so we did try to
control for that a little bit by like
having humans read the severity of their
flaws and whether they would have
noticed them otherwise they can still
see a significant effect
um but also like I mean a lot of the
time the model is nitpicking and then
those are like not the interesting cases
yeah
um also if you like look at the example
I showed which I think it's from the
blog post like a lot of the kids are
just actually quite garbage and one of
the like things that makes it easy for
critiques is
it's okay most of them are garbage
because the human can just beat them and
discard them and it kind of like
more you know helps evaluate it and know
where to focus on or like notice like
think of something they would have
missed otherwise
so it's more like you know the critiques
help you brainstorm how you should
evaluate or something
um but if you're kind of like using an
assistant you probably want more
reliability than like filling most of
the answers to why
um yeah
yes uh how do we ensure that the
evaluation metrics we are using in your
recursive word modeling approach like
detect deception or like left turns or
something don't have like major
discontinuity
yeah I think
yeah well it depends a lot what kind of
community you're talking about right
like if
you know you get overnight like a model
that is let's say a thousand inches
larger on like number of parameters or
like equivalently better
um
that can like create quite a step up and
that's makes it quite difficult to
do this kind of evaluation
um
so in that sense I think it's going to
be very important to like scale up AI
continue more continuously and like do
more incremental steps
um having said that I think
the basic picture with request number
one modeling is
that you're training the systems to help
you evaluate you know
systems that train from or fine-tune
from the same system right and so if you
can figure out how to get
like fine-tune them in a way that they
mention everything that is actually
useful and relevant then it would still
be able to
evaluate systems even though they're
much smarter than anything you've
evaluated before
maybe let me make this more concrete
because there's I think a way that you
could measure that or like one way we've
tried it was using what we called the
discriminator critique Gap
so to measure that you're training two
different or you're fine-tuning two
different models from this entry chain
model
one is a discriminator just says like
is this the flight response or the the
correct response or more correct
response
and the other one is a critique model
that tells you what the flaw was
and now you can measure how often does
the discriminator get it correctly and
the discriminator is just like pure
gradient descent it doesn't have to want
to tell you anything you just basically
hooking into the model through
presentations and trying to like get all
all the relevant latent Insight it has
to this prediction task and then on the
other side other hand you have this
critique model or this general
assistance model and you're measuring
how often does the assistant actually
help me point to the right flaw
and then if you compare these two scores
you can like look at the gap between
them hence this generally sorry
discriminated critique app
and then if the Gap is large then the
model knows a lot about the task it's
not telling you and so that would be
very worrying
and the Gap is small
then
um you know there's much
there's like fewer things that the model
is like not telling you yeah but I guess
there's like lots of value like
Insurance
that's right
that's why we want to test it on current
models
yes I don't know who was first I think
someone in the back
I
um
so I wanted to ask about like the
University
and so um you know I've been helping
it's like part of that also is like
communicating what you want the AI to do
right right not just like evaluating but
like communicating like perhaps like I
would like you to do this and maybe
maybe it can't do that
um and so like at least like in my
personal experience using the chat CPT
like there were some things that could
do that without really surprisingly
yeah one thing that I thought
um was a bit concerning was just this
idea that like you know people don't
always communicate their preferences
like
honestly or like like there could be
like uh like coordinated efforts right
to like like instill rewards for like
specific capabilities you know like
coordinated efforts to do such a thing
like one idea like I had a business like
I tried to ask if that has like some
idea of like a Wikipedia for itself like
I didn't know how to use it at first so
I just thought that maybe
walk there it is but like I was hoping
there was one there was one for like GPT
um and so my question is like
um
how do you like make that sort of like
being safe right like have you like
recognized coordinating efforts to like
you know like specifically reward
certain kinds of behavior
um maybe like some group of unfortunate
decides that they would like to
um yeah you know give it some capability
so this isn't you know like yeah this is
a really good question and like in a way
I mean the first obvious thing though
you shouldn't do is like you shouldn't
just like literally train in the data
that people you give through like using
the interface and we've kind of like
seen other examples of what happens we
do that if you think of like Microsoft
Ka or something that can go pretty wrong
um the other thing is I mean right now
what we're doing is like we're hiring a
bunch of people and then ask them to
rate different model responses but also
now the question becomes like you know
who will be hiring and like what's their
background what are they trying to do
and so
and in particular like the thing I think
we're doing quite poorly right now is
like actually
like importing like a diverse and
representative set of human preferences
and it's more just like you know whoever
we end up we can hire
um and so I kind of wish there was also
this like
more
targeted research on like how we should
do that and how that could be done well
and some of it is also like you know
better placed outside of like big tank
companies because if you are like tech
companies always have an incentive to
like you know
um
import human preferences in the way that
maybe is not like the thing that we
actually
Humanity would do under reflection or
something and so I think it's a really
big important question
like data contamination is like the Dual
problem to this like do you think
um
yeah I mean you have like is that
something people might can anyone can
poison the free training right just put
something on the Internet
um and it's you know something that we
have to be very mindful of
considering that we're currently
training these models
hopefully getting closer to human
purposes at this point as human
preferences change
yeah I mean the most obvious thing is
it's like the model's knowledge base is
kind of like the pre-training cutoff
date like somebody you know whatever
data you went into pre-training it
doesn't know about like a lot of things
that happened after that
um in terms of updating kind of like
human preferences or the you know like
the comparisons that go into the reward
model units collect more data and we
train the fine-tuning run is like
competitively cheap so you can you know
do that again
I think what gets harder is that you
know like
as you've deployed the model and people
started using it for all kinds of you
know tasks that they want to build their
company around like they
um if you're update and you change the
model then they also have to do a bunch
of work into like adapting their prompts
to whatever they have to do what they're
doing
and so it doesn't come as a zero cost
yes uh sorry yeah so on the note of
exceeding Human Performance but what if
the advantage of the gp3 is that it has
immense purpose of you guys can be
entire internet if you want to
specialize in a specific domain like
chemistry or Material Science or
something and especially to generate new
content
automatics
you mean like less data on like the
chemical domain or something yeah you
just have like research paper for the
last 30 years yeah and you can throw
that into pre-training right and then
the model knows about it but can the
model really learn us effectively
without so much data okay
yeah I mean that's kind of the general
idea with what you intend to do with
fine tuning and to some extent we've
seen it like generalized in this way for
example instruct gbt was trained almost
entirely on English
language feedback and demonstrations
and it works in other languages and so
that's kind of wild and so similarly you
know you could train the model with
people who don't know anything about
chemistry and then you know it learns to
follow instructions and it will do so
like on the topic of chemistry and this
fine tuning can be very sample efficient
like with 100 data points you can
actually make a meaningful change in the
Model Behavior
so it can be quite effective
um I'm gonna pick someone hasn't asked
yes
so what I've noticed from potentially
that it always gives you back very
structured or scientifically structured
answers do you
um consider in the training if it
returns you like a scientific scientific
research to answer or rather than
asterisk dance
yeah
I mean the tricky thing is ideally the
model should give you the kind of answer
that you
want to have right and some people
prefer a more scientific or technical
answers some people might prefer more
generic answer
and I mean it right now like chat GPT
doesn't have like you know a way for you
to set like your specific preferences
and that's something that you know would
be really exciting to have
um but also I think
the kind of stylistic property that
you've observed are is in fact like
probably a product of our labeler pool
and so a lot of the chachibi key workers
were like more you know like
I think more like computer sciencey and
like more there was like more data
generated by programmers
compared to instruct gbt which was more
like uh generalist labelers
and
and yeah there's like different it's
like kind of it changes also the style
um
yeah I mean
we should make a distinguished effort it
should give you like the style that you
want right
um
yes
so one of the things that I've been
thinking about
um
like in the education
and so as we go back to the graph of the
AI progress
the uh
human level yeah evaluate but I'm sorry
to think about is like over great I have
to use this sort of show like my 10 year
old cousin had a pair of chat GPT just
to mess around with
and that green line is a lot lower
um and furthermore if said just becomes
part of their educational experience
it's going to be much where I perceive
it to be more difficult for them to
discriminate even simpler tasks
and so I'm already thinking about like
how that might disrupt or make this
alignment a little bit more difficult in
the long run as you have people who are
more you know taped for instance what
Japanese
says as like a kid Intrigue anyway yep
um
I was just wondering what your what your
thoughts are I mean there's a real risk
of overlying on a text that is immature
and that is not ready for you know
you just believing like please don't
believe everything the model says right
right um but also I think one thing
that I'm hopeful for is that like you
know your cousin will end up like
figuring out how to do this where like
you know they grew up with uh you know
like all of these AI tools that are
getting better and learning how to
actually leverage them productively
right and like it's kind of like
you know uh 20 years ago or something
when you were like you like using Google
search much earlier than everyone else
you're probably gonna get better at like
using that as a tool for everything you
want to do
um
I think you headed your hand up for last
yeah
um
oh wait the last one
yeah so but right now it seems like you
guys are
it was just biological sensors to the
real world the like physical grouchy and
using language as like a compressed
interface to that ground truth are you
guys also looking at using uh like
sensor technology directly with your
models to get a more truthful answer of
you know
yeah
I mean it depends on what that sense you
could be right like I guess like one of
the most straightforward things is you
could ask the model to browse and then
it can like fact check its own answers
and it can you know like
import external knowledge that I didn't
remember
and
um
yeah I think that would be quite useful
I think that'll be quite useful for
assisting human evaluation
um
and you can look at web GPT which you
know isn't published work on using the
model for browsing
um I think so one thing that makes it
harder when you're using this like
external sensors or if you
letting the model interact more directly
with the real world is that it raises
more safety questions right if you let
your language model make arbitrary API
calls then you have to be a lot more
careful with which calls there's a lot
to make and which is it not and if you
as opposed to if you're just like
reviewing everything the model says then
you can decide which ones you want to
make
um
so yeah
it's an open crop
okay one more question
uh I think you didn't
using the abilities of these kind of
I've seen like different people talk
about how I was only like a
face-to-matic compute per token while a
human they have system one system two
where we can like just speak quickly
versus actually using reasoning and
think through things that's different
effort and then I've seen other words to
try to like kind of use the force it to
achieve it from the chain of the
reasoning or like let's think step by
step do you think that stuff is
sufficient to do like everything because
you want or will require real big
fine-tuning or architectural changes
I don't know
I'm also the wrong person to ask
I'm mostly not trying to get the models
to have new capabilities and more like
you know getting them to play on team
human
um oh do we want to do the online
questions
so what do you think is the is
more often out
uh
yeah quite possibly
um
I mean yeah as you find out right like
there is a lot of conversational data
and if you can use that that would be
that should should be useful
um I think broadly can categorize this
kind of thing it was like let's make the
RL algorithm better and like I would
also need feedback and I think that's
valuable and that should help us like
make the same free chain models like
more aligned according to the human
preferences that we collected
um
but also you would still run into like
all the limitations that rlhf has right
I don't think it offers a role right now
but it's supervised fine-tuning so you
could do like you can like there's still
best of them and do this kind of expert
iteration
uh so the first question is could you
more clearly describe the full training
process for child GPT example starting
with the best
201c.001 then xdd or program data of Y
step so I left
sorry I didn't I didn't catch that start
with text Adventure zero zero one and
then so how much uh
how many steps of part of that pitch
kind of things
um
I think the exact numbers are not public
uh it's basically similar to instruct
gbt and for the instructory BT numbers
um we had
I think around 50 000 comparisons and
probably like 10 000 demonstrations or
like maybe tens of thousands I don't
remember the exact number
um so I had like this other slide with
uh yeah I was like about 20 000 hours of
human feedback that's what I calculated
because that's you can get like one
million or whatever attractions you want
right I mean the big question is like
how do you make how do you ensure
quality
um
but it's the whole problem right like
that assumes you already have the reward
model that you trust so
yeah so
I mean
the kind of like ambition of that plan
is to train a model that can do this
kind of conceptual research
and you know you know you can picture
the like a language model that like you
know writes an alignment research paper
that we you know like we read and then
we're like oh this is a really cool idea
we should try this
um and I think
you know going back to evaluation is
easier in generation I think it also
applies to alignment research and like I
think at the very least like I find it
much easier to evaluate you know
alignment research than I find it to
like produce it and so
while there might be conceptual break
shoes that we need that we couldn't even
evaluate right now because they're just
like you know if we saw them we'd be
like what is this
um and this is kind of like part like
this is like the reason why we want to
do scalable oversight right because like
if you know the language model produces
this really brilliant insight and we
can't even recognize it at the time
um we should be able to have an easier
time recognizing it if we use EI
assistance and if we leverage like our
best AI models
to like figure out whether or not that
was a good idea what it was the
weaknesses and what are the strengths
and like you know what kind of
experiments should we run to know
whether this is a good idea and so
yeah I think basically
you know the story of just using our lhf
to train a model to do good alignment
research
you have the obvious pitfalls which is
you know the model might write like an
alignment proposal that kind of looks
good to us but it's actually you know
not a good proposal and it creates AI
that is misaligned with humans
um and so in order to distinguish it too
which might be really hard maybe it's
not but you know I think we should
expect it to be really hard and then
leveraging EI assistance to evaluate
that seems like a really
promising plan
I mean that was my whole point it's not
sufficient
what do you think like do you need like
something more or if you wanted what
companies trying to do do you think like
uh if you can like get a lot of feedback
data will that be sufficient to get a
various Generations or to be receiving
more
I mean the journalists or like
I think the
[Music]
um
basically the vast majority of the
models capabilities and like all the
cool things you see it do come from
pre-training and now it's from the fine
tuning stage the reason why people
sometimes attribute to the fine-tuning
stage is that you didn't see it in the
pre-trained model
and the reason I think the reason that
we didn't see it in the pre-trade model
is because the payment model was so
misaligned it was not trying to help you
and it was not trying to show you all
the things it can do and instead it just
regurgitates a bunch of random web text
and that's not what you're looking for
and so
yeah I think what Jeff basically has
been doing is like unlocking
capabilities that we're already in the
model
and making those available for humans to
use
and in some ways like
you know alignment research is very dual
use in the sense that you know a if you
have really good alignment techniques
you can use it to align with whatever
values you want including values that
you know we wouldn't particularly
endorse and B
it also
like if you're doing alignment right it
will always look a little bit like your
midday AI system more capable because
before it was wasn't really trying that
hard to help you and now you've made it
more aligned so you know you actually
see these capabilities you already had
um sure that's it
um Japanese
history
[Music]
documented for this decides to
incentivize deception so how will
contribute yeah so that was what I was
talking about here right like
um
this is like the whole problem that we
have where what humans about can
evaluate is constant and so we won't be
able to evaluate like sophisticated
attempts at deceiving us and that's why
we want to do scalable supervision so
that we Empower humans to spot these
attempts at Deception
uh
familiar network marketing inertness
alignments decisions
yeah so
I think it's a real worries and
to some extent we kind of like have to
test empirically like how
difficult and how severe they actually
are
um I think so my personal stance right
now is something like I think trying to
get the outer alignment signal really
right is going to be like 90 of the
effort
and once we have that then a lot of the
other things might also fall into place
so for example
I mean it kind of depends on which story
of any misalignment you're worried about
but you know one story is
you kind of training assistant and it
learns how to do
it like learns basically a bunch of you
know optimizers kind of like meta
reinforcement learning
so for example like gpg3 you can do like
in context learning and that's like a
kind of you know learned optimizer
and so now you're like doing our lhf
training or whatever like alignment
training you have and you're like the
the line optimizers land you do the
thing that you want on distribution
but now if you have a distributional
shift and this distributional shift
could be auto-induced meaning like the
model is causing it itself
um now you're going out of the
distribution all these inner optimizers
like try to optimize for something else
and
one way you could like
and you know like how much that would
actually happen practice kind of I'm
clear but one kind of like more
important question is like if you have a
really reliable outer alignment signal
and you have this like General training
signal that you trust you can also use
that you know on the new distribution to
train the system to be
more
or like to get this inner optimizes in a
row basically and so then you produce
like the inner alignment problems too
like how do you deal with distributional
shift and how do you like construct an
outer alignment signal that you trust
and those are problems that we have to
deal with anyways
um
but yeah I don't I don't know how it's
actually going to shake out but
um this is some important open questions
um
so regarding uh alignments one of the
kind of
problems is
to see is that much interest it seems to
like explaining why because
decomposing these models is like
explaining why even circumstances are
fairly well I mean that's definitely the
two corralities but
um as to why it's making these uh
have a lot of judgments have you all
been able to interrogate them
I mean I think
where we are right now is like pretty
deceptive despite satisfactory
um I mean you can ask the model why it
gave a certain response but you don't
know whether it's answering truthfully
and you can also I mean another thing
you can do is you can give the model its
own its response and ask it to find out
flaws which is what we did in the
Clinique's paper
um but you know I think the like
I mean there's one version where you try
to make that better but then the
question is like what has you gone to a
signal
um I think like better angle of attack
is probably interpretability
where you know like you figure out how
to look inside the model and then
that's what I was asking about the level
of research is yeah it's like it seems
that that's it really is
yeah
your current thinking is moving towards
collect that race like reducing the
nationality of that uh
yeah I mean we are working on that
problem but I don't think we have
anything that is like to show right now
and so
um it seems generally not to be a very
easy problem but you know I'm I'm
hopeful that we can do some things I
think in general
the problem of interpretability or like
using interpretability for alignment is
kind of tricky because
I suspect it's going to be neither it's
going to be not sufficient and it might
not be necessary so any amount of
integral you can you can leverage would
be useful because it's another tool in
your toolbox of like detecting deception
or like knowing you know what you said
like how why the model gave a certain
answer and made a certain decision and
start
you know it is
kind of unclear if you really get really
good at interpretability how you then
leverage that
for alignment like presumably you could
look in the model and just like throw
all the models out that you can find in
misalignment in but then aren't you just
selecting for models that have
misalignments they're really hard to
find with you and show you the body
tools
sure sure
does not be necessary
yes so why would it not be necessary so
again this is kind of like an open
question but
basically what stance you could take is
that at the end of the day what really
is going to matter is the decisions that
the model actually takes and not the
reasons why it took them and so if you
can get to the point where you're
confident that all the things the model
actually does
are aligned with what you want
then does it still matter what the model
thinks internally
I don't know
yeah
of the model yeah that's that's what
we're trying to do right like we're
trying to make like a really really good
evaluation signal
and then you can select for you know you
can train the model to do the things
that you wanted to do because you can
just always evaluate better than the
model can do stuff
um
but yeah thanks so much for the great
lecture very interesting
to do like a live on uh just like uh
application thing yeah sure sure
eyeglass sorry
oh yeah
thank you